Một mấy trường pháp, trong nguyên bè rốt ngày 1,5 mấy tạo quan ngại xúc sắc về các chiếc quân sự của Mỹ tại của biển Cái Bên,
cho rằng như họ đậm này bị phạm lật tóc của tế và của Mỹ cơ gây mất ổ định khu vực.
Pháp biểu bên lệ hội nghiên quan trường của Mỹ tại thành phố Nhi Agarara, on the leg của cả nader,
ông bè rốt như mạnh pháp có lạnh thủ hành ngoại trong khu vực Cái Bên, người hơn một chợt công dân xí sống,
vì vậy, bà rì đặc biệt lòng ai trước những hành động quân sự có thế giận đến lâu thang càng thang.
Chợt đậu đậu Mỹ đã tiền hàng ít nhất mới chính của không kích nhằm và các tạo thuyền được cho là buôn mặt thuy ở của biển Cái Bên và của biển Tha Bình dường gần bị lạ tình.
Khi đến ít bệnh bị sống với thật mạc, Washington càng định đây là các chiến dịch trong tội phạm xuyên của ra,
sau nhiều nước trong khu vực mào của ông Bên nè dùy là và khu vah,
các buộc Mỹ đang mở giọng gịt dễ quan sức để gây sự gách chiến.
Lì là của cũng đã lấy nạn chiến dễ quan sức và yêu còn bị dừng hành động hả xa nhìn mạc,
mạc không thông qua mất kịt, quy trình sẽ xử nào.
Cũng liên quan tối tình hành gây bê, khiến towsen by USS,
gerat, r4, cùng tảng tổ chiến, một tổ ngầm hành nhân và nhiều tiêm pic em mạm mấy lạm giết đã có mặt tại buông biển khu vực.
Tổng thống Bên nè dù là cá vục Mỹ đang chiến phay lực lợt nhằm lật lộ,
chỉ quyền cơ gà s, trong khi Washington mắc bỏ,
nó mục tiêu là bảo đam, tư dò hàng hải và ổn đị khu vực.